she's like chinese people look like
this like japanese people have more of a
downward angle like this
and then everything in the middle is
everything else
everything else she's an educator she
thought this is going to be a pro house
i don't understand like where's this
lady coming from like where the [ __ ]
what
where where the [ __ ] when she born bro
how could you think that that's all a
good idea there's
so many asian people in sacramento
in five four three two one
hello everybody como estas once again
muy bien
uh
i mean i got i told you i've been taking
my spanish
the way you taped myself was like that's
that's real legit
yeah yeah that was good bro you got it
you're right do a canelo real quick do a
canelo
oh my voice is not nowhere near high
pitched enough did you watch the canelo
fight i didn't i heard he murdered this
there's
literally no point he just bullied him
dude yeah yeah
he kept throwing the same punches over
and over again and was landing him over
and over again
and then he fell down so i'm surprised
he didn't piss out blood he was
hitting him in the liver so hard it was
terrible we're gonna find out if he was
pissing blood for sure
that he was getting [ __ ] up dude
there's like nobody for him to fight i
feel like who's gonna who's like a
legit contender for besides like triple
g or
i mean was he supposed to fight billy
saunders or what would you yeah billy
joe saunders yeah uh something happened
i think he didn't like pass the drug
i don't know dude yeah the box it's hard
so hard to keep up with boxing nowadays
watch he's probably gonna end up
fighting like a jorge monster doll or
some [ __ ]
or him they're looking for money right
now yeah like yeah i think that makes
sense if no one's willing to fight uh
canelo
like the cross promotion probably does
make sense but
what have you been up to pat just
chilling bro just working being a papa
papa just [ __ ] corn don't forget you
have a [ __ ] kid me too sometimes i'll
be like
randomly driving i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm a
father like someone depends
like oh no i gotta work yeah i got a
douche
i got a mouth to feed you let's support
this [ __ ] child of mine yeah
sometimes i look at her i'm like damn
i'm your dad bro
what's it like supporting a child uh
it's stressful you know what i mean it's
[ __ ]
stressful i just break down crying
not honestly it's chill i mean it is
like it does put a fire under your ass
but like
it's so cool like kicking it with them
and they're like so cute and [ __ ]
yeah i mean i think i i i'm biased
obviously she's my daughter maybe to you
guys she's annoying as [ __ ] but to me
like i love her we're all like we all
admit like yo we [ __ ] hate her
yeah yo maya's a [ __ ] though the way
she looked at me
sometimes though like when i'm trying to
get her to eat like i'll get her i'll
like she's real picky about
food and she'll be like today earlier
today i was like come on eat your
vegetables she'll be like no
just like turn around like be like under
my brush just like stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] you come on say llama daddy come on
you're a [ __ ] and then she's like yeah
you're just like your
[ __ ] mother that [ __ ] never eats
vegetables she hates vegetables and she
hates me too
we're in a court case right now so it's
gonna look real bad
when they play it in court they'll be
like see he's on there call of duty
no no no that is me i actually never met
her before yeah she's probably perfectly
fine
she's not but it's okay
[Laughter]
um this will pat texas me because i the
other day i was in um
i was i posted a story on instagram so
in past south pasadena there's a spot
called jones coffee
right they they provide a coffee for kos
and pie they're they're their whole
roasters and everything else like that
so every day around like 2 to 4 p.m
around there there's a dude named hassan
assan is a homeless guy very [ __ ]
talented
i think he's on the spectrum a bit i
think a lot of those dudes that said
that are on
are on the spectrum but he's very
[ __ ] talented so he plays like all
this
old timey-ass ragtime piano [ __ ] did you
see him there before
yeah i've seen him before but he's there
all the time and he's
[ __ ] ripping it let me tell you
something this day was probably one of
the funniest days
i've ever had in my life oh so me and
khalif we go
to check out hassan right and we always
give him tips specifically kalief
because i never carry cash and i just
kind of
say that i yeah add it to the you're
piggybacking yeah i picked him back off
his charity
usually hassan plays by himself hassan
can actually sing too by the way
he has great vocals and he actually
writes his own music so he has a song
that he plays out there called like
miseries folly or something it's really
dope
but on this special day from a distance
i see a guy with a guitar there too
and i'm like oh [ __ ] he got a [ __ ]
band together now this is dope
so i walk up you see hassan playing his
old timey ass [ __ ] saloon music
and then you see this dude with the
guitar [ __ ] off key as [ __ ]
doesn't know what's going on and he's
just sitting there
just trying to keep up with the song
so i'm assuming what happened was hassan
was playing the piano then he asked
hassan
hey you mind if i play the guitar with
you and that sounds like sure why not
and hassan starts going in and he goes
aw [ __ ]
so he starts playing random chords so
hassan's playing and he's getting so
i'm irritated as [ __ ] too because i'm
just trying to hear hassan he's ruining
the experience yeah
he just thought he goes hey can i just
play by myself huh and he goes got it he
gets up
oh he told hips yeah he gets up goes to
another table starts playing all off-key
bro all sad stuck bro even when he plays
by himself he's off key
even but by himself he's just he doesn't
know how to play the guitar
okay he's just a dude with a guitar he's
a homeless dude with a guitar that
doesn't know how to play the [ __ ]
guitar
he tried to hop in thinking that he was
going to keep up with his han and hassan
is [ __ ] dope
yeah he's a beast that guy's a g i've
seen him a lot that place jones it used
to be a place called busters
but like i used to go there i've been
going there forever but that corner is
perfect for people watching because
there's
always weirdos bro i've seen some of the
funniest [ __ ] there
like there used to be this guy he ended
up he ended up being called the pasadena
piper
i didn't know who he was yeah yeah yeah
yeah the first element dude david's old
car
way way before like the newspaper
articles i saw him there i was just like
writing because
that was like where i go to write and i
just heard
you and i'm like what the [ __ ] look up
this guy's blasting adele and he's with
his like little recorder and he's like
this old white dude jamming out dark
brown hair like
hard as [ __ ] bro windows down there's
people like leaning out their windows or
their apartments they're like don't hurt
yourself now
was that me bro
yo lips look chapped why don't you come
up for some sweet tea honey
and this [ __ ] bro that corner that
coffee shop is amazing because i
i always see the phony and [ __ ] i saw
that recorder guy when i was coming
outside of fight academy pasadena
yeah and then he had a honda element and
i immediately stole my car afterwards
i can't be associated with this [ __ ]
man here
that spot is so weird it's because it's
next to the the metro
and so sometimes these people who are
not all mentally there they always stop
by and jones
they're not going to kick them out they
actually play ice and they give them
some drinks yeah so they get to chill
yeah so there's this other dude that was
there
[ __ ] japanese guy which surprisingly
looks like joe in 10 years
right he had like the ponytails and
[ __ ] everything he's wearing a full
samurai outfit
let me tell you something dude this dude
was [ __ ] weird and so hassan
he's playing the piano but the japanese
dude is just talking to himself in his
thick japanese accent saying just
[ __ ] gibberish hassan stops he goes
hey can you just stop being an [ __ ]
for a second
and he goes well what's appropriate
by the way i am not exaggerating how
he's talking he talks like when joe
makes fun of japanese people yeah that's
what he sounds like
i actually wrote down for you guys oh
yeah oh yes
do you like that hassan just a [ __ ]
handling business tell anybody
like it is he's like yo i'm trying to
play my [ __ ] old-timey music right
now yeah and you're [ __ ] up the vibe
bro so
this japanese dude is sitting there and
mind you i'm just giving you a picture
he has like
flip-flops he's dirty as [ __ ] and
this is what he says to him he goes i
used to steal the cigarette
right so you curiously you mentally
deserve a cigarette giving me a
cigarette
and the son goes i should have never
given you a cigarette at all you're an
[ __ ] so the story lines about the
cigarette
and then this japanese dude is just
laughing
like a [ __ ] villain is he is he a
small slender man no he has his square
ass [ __ ] face he looks like a lego
honestly he looks like japanese gilbert
all the time the picture you sent me he
wasn't sitting at the table he was on
his knees like yeah like that
like just sitting on his head with this
perfect posture
and so after that he got really japanese
four bottles next to him and then he
like continues to talk to him then he
says
what i say he sucks i say he sucks
point again i saw him he sucks
santos around you're a [ __ ] dick
right
and back to it and then he's like
playing his old-timey ass music
yeah and after a while like he starts
being kind of a dick towards his son
because hassan wants him to go away yeah
and so the japanese dude just walks up
and then he puts a chair next to
hassan's piano
and just sits there and he's like super
close to him and hassan's like bye
get out of here get the [ __ ] out of here
bye just continue to [ __ ] play
and then he writes i don't even have a
headline
stop and let me sing when we having sex
with a movie star we say
shut up shut up oh yeah oh yeah but what
about politician
i mean you're a fan you're like a sex
time
i thought i really wrote it down wow
cause i
i'm doing a case study on this this is a
legal document now
he goes you're chinese a fan you know
he's [ __ ] japanese wow dude
are you sure it wasn't joe jitsukawa huh
this sounds all in line with judges
let me tell you something this is the
line that just made me think he was
crazy at this point
he goes oh it wasn't the other stuff
because this sentence makes no sense he
goes the point is
i'm your fan it's a twister
and this motherfucker's over here just
saying he gave him a cigarette he's not
even appreciative of it you know what's
so [ __ ] weird
though like in my heart i was like i
actually thought to myself and i was
super quiet
i'm like am i have am i gonna have to
intervene here yeah and like tell this
dude the [ __ ] off
but at the same time i'm like there's so
many asian attacks yeah so i was
thinking what i was going to do
is that i was going to shove him i was
going to stop hassan
right and say it's black history month
don't worry i got you and i'm going to
suck the japanese dude
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we police
our own
hey but loki that's kind of true though
the racially asian attacks in black
history month it was very odd
yeah you're in a pickle dude damn dude
and i think you i think you did the
right thing i think you
intervened properly by not intervening
at all at all
i was gonna say something but if i say
hey can you stop he's going to open up a
conversation with me
yeah and then i'm fine yeah you're
talking to him and the six other spirits
who are involved in that conversation as
well
you know so you don't want to do that he
sees all the spirits from mulan and [ __ ]
like all the ancestors that's what he
sees in his head he was so [ __ ] weird
so just
rubber bands here pigtails sticking all
the way the [ __ ] out
dirt all over his face and he went aside
to get uh
to get a cup of ice comes out he goes
i'm really thirsty
and he takes the ice cup and he just
puts it on his eye
bro because you didn't see his son sock
him in the [ __ ] eye that's what you
did the thug was being really chill
about it though
how did it end like how did it conclude
what happened hassan was like i gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here
i need some weed cigarettes
self-medicating like a [ __ ] what
this means is we have to go to jones
next week and we have to observe dude
let's go to jones i love jones bro i
miss going to coffee shops
and i can i'm literally telling you this
is what i did oh [ __ ] let me see this is
what he looks like it's a very artistic
photo but
the story behind it is terrible he's
good how like sensual he's hugging that
like he's like
those ponytails are nice this just shows
how good
david is at taking photos that is a
great picture though it's a great
picture
like and then that geo right there yeah
if he had an instagram picture that
would be his profile that would be
his profile pic this looks like this cup
of ice and this dude are in love dude
and then he's crossing his [ __ ] does
he have knee pads on too
dude you got rain boots on that dude's
calves are amazing though how many
jackets does he have on dude like 17.
he's got he has like a sweater over like
a long military jacket do you see that
yeah that cape yeah you got a mask under
here ready to go do this
who's gone wild would be proud his
[ __ ] socks are highest yeah
they're high bro look how high those
socks are dude but you see those [ __ ]
massive calves
yeah yeah yeah they're doing at them
things running hills dude with those
spirits they're making them run hills
you're just doing calf raises all the
time this guy i just couldn't believe
what i was witnessing all in one day and
you know what else happened that day
this is how weird this [ __ ] day was
it's always on that street too
this guy on that street where jones is
you getting into some crazy
some weird [ __ ] doug so me and khalif
were walking by now
if you guys don't know south pasadena
south pasadena is a hoity-toity nice ass
[ __ ] area right
toity minus you know little japanese
samurai weirdo here with the kids yes
but he's harmless but so if you just
walk up in south pass
it's kind of like the south you say hi
to people people greet you back you go
spark up random conversation people
usually smile
so when we were walking up khalif spot
sparked up a conversation with an older
lady who has an older dog
just like his they went on for 10 15
minutes it was great so on the way back
after we just saw that
debauchery of a [ __ ] scene we're
walking back like yo what the [ __ ]
happened and so this lady
who is relatively out of shape
right but she's setting up all those all
the uh the ladder [ __ ]
she has her dumbbells out kettlebells or
whatever and you know khalif is working
on his nassim stuff
yeah and he looks like he waves or says
hi he goes hey he goes oh are you are
you working on some hit stuff
and then she just ignores him he's like
what the [ __ ] he goes
oh i was just wondering if you're doing
like a hit exercise right she goes
yeah i'm a trainer oh oh wow and then i
was like hold on what the hell
the [ __ ] was that about and we had to
stop and think about it i think she
thought he was
hitting on her he she legit thought
he was like hollering at her like cat
calling her he was like no
hit training you dumb [ __ ] we're
talking about the [ __ ] modality of
workout that you're doing right here
it's very popular have you heard of it
you're a trainer right so you must be
familiar with hit training
we were like sitting there kind of
thinking like what the [ __ ] was that
okay shamu
this guy was like she's over like what
did you say
you said
based on their looks all right i think
everybody has beauty on the inside and
out of course
of course
but but we all know we all know what
khalif looks like that is a handsome
light
man yeah he's right it is like he was in
the boondocks but came out and became a
real person
the sexy well-kept version of everything
yeah yeah
i'm like my dear lady you are not in his
league
absolutely not yeah yeah you are a
little slobbingly
yeah slovenly foreign
if a random person comes up to you and
you have workout equipment on the
sidewalk
and they're like hey hit training huh
would you
ever think that person was hitting on
you though yeah what the [ __ ] because uh
no i'm a trainer it's like oh okay but
doesn't answer my question
i was just saying are you doing hit
training no okay then you leave
south pasadena is weird in the sense
where it's like really nice like you
said but it can also be really
[ __ ] like that it's like wait what the
[ __ ] like where did that come from like
we're just trying to be chill baby
what's going on yeah what's up
i was like you should just walk up and
then whenever she's training her clients
to steal all of her clients
yeah that sounds like she has asperger's
i'm a trainer oh yeah well i want to
[ __ ] you
that's what she was thinking internet
like he wanted
but now she's going to go off and
probably do a little facebook post
talking about
well today this man was cat calling me
and i told him
no yeah like no he was a trainer
it's like okay hey what cool he just
wanted to give you like some
morning motivation to say hey you're
doing hit training good job yeah and she
came back
i'm a trainer like i'm a trainer [ __ ]
you don't look like it
yeah yeah i'll tell you that right now
you look like me [ __ ] the [ __ ] you
talking about you slaving
yeah you slaving you cool
you're [ __ ] what did kelly say after
that
was just like shocked he woke up this
morning pissed off
he's like it took him like three days to
practice he's like what the [ __ ] is
going on with that [ __ ] he woke up this
morning he just wrote he just texted me
he goes
no i'm a trainer
you're
because everybody at south pass is
usually really nice yeah she just
snapped at him
yeah that's weird that's [ __ ] weird
and i know everybody got to deal with
their own [ __ ] she probably had to deal
with stuff
but that question doesn't warrant that
response
yeah i don't understand the question how
she got there from that
you know that doesn't make any sense
what a weird interaction dude
maybe she just hates hit training maybe
she maybe she's just super against it
dude
i am a trainer i'm gonna get a sex
change and beat her ass dude that would
be bad
just you don't even have to get a sex
change just identify as a woman for a
little bit oh yeah
just be gender fluid can you do that now
i thought about it
you know what back to
i don't know i don't know i don't know i
mean look
didn't somebody do that as a power
lifter they said like oh identified as a
woman and then he broke the record and
was like all right now oh [ __ ] that
that's hella crazy yeah yeah
there's always gonna be somebody who's
gonna bend those rules i mean like
he's not he was doing he's like a dude
yeah he was making a point this podcast
is brought to you by purple
my friends have you ever heard of purple
mattresses
if you haven't that must mean you're
sleeping on a bag of crap
yeah you're sleeping in poopy you ever
go to your girlfriend's house and she
sleeps
on a bag of coals and you're like wow
lady you don't care about me
or maybe you slept at your boyfriend's
house and you're like whoa guy
cut off your pee pee because you don't
care about me that's because
the stuff that they are sleeping on they
think it's good enough for you and
it's not well purple my friends is
reinvented only purple
has the grid a stretchy gel material
that's amazingly supportive for your
back and legs while cushioning your
shoulders
necks and hips my friends my purple
mattress feels amazing
i have never slept so great in my life i
sleep so well
that i could just talk and talk for days
because if you sleep well your cognitive
ability goes
up your mood is better everything is
great we spend a
fat chunk of our lives on our back
sleeping or our sides
well guess what you might as well bless
it with some purple baby well check it
out my friends
purple really is comfort for an
uncomfortable world
right now you'll get 10 off any order of
200 or more go to purple.com
gb10 and use promo code gb10
that's purple.com gb10 promo code gb10
for 10
off any order of 200 or more or
purple.com gb10 promo code gb10
terms apply speaking of canceling
started messaging me about that [ __ ]
teacher in sacramento
oh yeah i ate a squinty eyes what
happened she goes this is what she was
doing she goes
so china she was on zoom she's like
chinese people look like this
like japanese people have more of a
downward angle like this
and then everything in the middle is
everything else
everything else and she's the educator
she thought this is going to be a pro
house
i don't understand like where's this
lady coming from like where the [ __ ]
what
where where the [ __ ] when she born bro
like how could you think that that's all
a good idea there's so many asian people
in sacramento it's crazy like we
literally have like a whole vietnam town
and everything and that's why you want
to trust your opinion because she hangs
out with a lot of asians so she knows
the angles
did you see a japanese guy
might be in poor taste but very true
yeah also
why are you doing that yeah you know at
all why not just avoid all that spectrum
of problems and just don't do that
you know like somebody what do you need
to do yeah why do that do this to your
husband at home yeah
no one's watching like the good old days
yeah
like behind our backs like just do it
behind her she was serious she wasn't
like trying to be funny or anything i
mean it's an interesting
place it's an inappropriate place to try
to be funny but like
at least if there's that element to it
like maybe a saving grace but not
there was a couple of kids who came out
and said that
the the clip was like taken out of
context but i'm trying to figure out
what the context is that
still that makes it okay because you're
a teacher dude the only context that
makes sense is if she's having a rose
battle with one of her students
and that student just zinged the [ __ ]
out of herself and then she's like [ __ ]
i gotta go racial baby atomic
the only thing i was thinking is like
maybe she's like a stand-up comic at
night and she forgot she was teaching a
class
yeah yeah yeah she just read the lenny
bruce book and like
i saw the key though if she did that on
a stand-up comedy club and she did that
joke probably would have killed
probably not to be honest
i know comedy bro you don't do comedy
that would have murdered that's what
nobody
likes that's so true everybody loves
racial jokes that would have been her
opening dude yeah straight up she just
comes out hey guys so
chinese people you guys ever notice how
chinese people's eyes are like this yeah
that's their opening kareem's eyes are
like this
everyone's like they're chanting her
name they love her bro
that was so [ __ ] weird man i want to
see the whole video i want to see what
the what led up to it because that's the
first thing i thought was like
how did this unfold a [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ]
what are you doing if i was the the vice
principal of the principal and i had had
to have a conversation with her i just
like
hey [ __ ] just teach yeah yeah yeah just
just just [ __ ] teach
what are you doing like you're out you
don't to go to the classroom yeah
you're good i'm sure it's much harder
kind of but at the same time
you don't got to get out of bed yeah
like what are you doing just teach
yeah just teach dude what do you do
where at all
did you think that that was remotely
okay like wait what thought
i want to know the thought process that
led to i'm actually kind of yeah i want
to know
i want to know like where because she
went from okay i'm gonna start my class
all right it's 805 students coming in
you do roll
and you know what just asians look like
this
and then she goes into the morning
announcements yeah yeah what was the
segway
yeah where how did she get there she was
collecting homework online
everyone was sending her homework and
then she was like hey guys have you guys
ever noticed this
you know what the topper is i thought
she was like maybe sometimes like social
studies teacher she's the [ __ ]
spanish teacher
for real wow she teaches language she
should have been like ojos are like this
chinitos are like this
bro wow that's so crazy just take a
couple spanish words you mix it in the
curriculum you're good i gotta watch
that clip i haven't seen that it's
really
it's it's it's [ __ ] funny dude
because you're you
that's that's so foul that's the
question it's like what the [ __ ] was she
thinking
that's what you want to know or or like
what led up to this
because the a the girl that was filming
it i don't know what she said but she
was [ __ ] mad she's like
i got this on camera i'm gonna [ __ ]
send this i forgot what she was saying
but she was like look she sounded so
uncool though yeah she could have just
recorded and just shut the [ __ ] up but
she was like i got this
i got it yeah yeah yeah you're really
uncool right now
she finally broke the case yeah her
racist ass teacher so she was
maybe like throughout the whole year
prior to zoom she's every time she did
roll call she goes and
that's all she's even calling by her
name
yeah sound effects that's how you
associate your [ __ ] students
oh my god bro girl that's so funny what
were you saying that reminds me that the
the teacher uh that it was like an old
clip the guy that like dropped an n bomb
in class do you remember that white dude
oh i love that guy that's what a pencil
can you like okay
yeah yeah bro but at least he was coming
from a place of like oh i'm trying to
teach
you know obviously you can't do that
[ __ ] now but like back then he was
trying to teach a subject like oh this
is
we're diving deeper into the the culture
a little bit he seemed genuinely
confused he had two
note cards he like brought he like made
note cards he was a confused dog he knew
what the [ __ ] it was
he was confused why people were so
offended yeah he's like he's like i did
the research like this
this is the er one and this is the a8
it was the way he emphasized it yeah
it sounded like he was teaching a bunch
of ignorant white people yeah right
yeah it was an actual school curriculum
he goes here you [ __ ] dummies
yeah er is racist but ah
he's like what's up my ah but at the end
of the day
he was doing his job yeah this woman's
job is not to differentiate between
asian eyes from china to japan to the
rest of them
and also very wrong that [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] funny though i feel like
when i remember a bunch of homies saw
that [ __ ] right they're like nah he good
because you know he's coming from a good
place and he's like yo i'm like i'm all
about it like
that's all the comments too it's like
man i'm black he ain't racist
he invited the cookout
he was just trying to educate people
yeah and and he wasn't
wrong you know what i mean like well
that video is so funny
if enough people co-sign you that's why
it went viral bro like imagine
if it was very important that [ __ ]
wouldn't go viral the way it did
yeah i just like how he was so adamant
that he was right
yeah which i guess he was back and then
it was okay yeah he was like what did i
do
they hired him to teach an ebonics class
that's just so
[ __ ] i think that's the backstory on
that wait after that was that's what
that's that's why he was talking about
it i think wasn't that the thing it was
like no it's because
he like called a student he said that to
a student or something that's like what
got him in trouble i just made that up
yeah no he there was a student that was
like this dude
dropped an n-bomb on really i and then
he was like and the
the teacher was kind of confused like
well he's like well he was like a very
like
he seemed really like he didn't
understand yeah and he was just like
well they
it's like people are saying it all the
time so he was like i just said it like
well sit down
blah yeah you said it and then he was
like i just don't understand he's like
the
i didn't say it with the er he's like
that's when he brought out his like
hooked on phonics [ __ ] yeah
he was like the phonetics the the
funniest part of that video too
was when he was giving the 17 examples
of how to use it
and that [ __ ] was smooth as [ __ ] yeah
like he's used that word his whole
life that pencil one yeah
can you land a a pencil yeah can you let
a ninja pencil
the way you said it too yeah he was like
i need you please
and the reporter is a black lady the
whole time he's talking to a black lady
wide open she's like she's like yeah
actually this all checks out
she's like actually no idea oh my god
yeah [ __ ] video you know how i know
this school doesn't give a [ __ ] about
asian plight dude
right when jeremy lin was called
coronifier
virus this man laughed wow you laughed
i'm daring no i didn't laugh man
i'm with you uh jeremy lin he laughed at
jeremy lin's face
that's what do you have to say for
yourself you know what
people are hey people people are gonna
people are gonna call you coronavirus
bro
huh have you been called coronavirus no
then you don't know my struggle bro
david have anyone called you cobra virus
i've been called you people
oh yeah well some of you people they're
like it's because of you people
yeah wow i've never felt so empowered in
my life
i've been waiting for somebody to call
me that [ __ ] did you [ __ ] punch him
in the face no he just no everybody else
defended me
uh where were you what happened i was at
la monarca
across the street from jones yeah yeah i
was at la monaca where ever everything
pops off over there yes lady that's what
i was having podcast before but this
lady uh
okay let's just be honest i went to la
monaca because there was this lady with
a fat ass
following her there's like i gotta take
a better look at this in there sometimes
long story short this lady she's just
she's like she called herself a cover
nurse and she was freaking out and there
was this other lady the lady with the
fat ass
that was there and she had a kid okay
and the kid got a little close to the
other lady and she had a stroller
and she goes excuse me you need to give
me space blah blah blah
okay whatever and then she just starts
going off on the other lady right she
goes ma'am i am a coveted nurse
and you are not six feet apart and the
lady with the big ass
the fat ass the juicy one is also a
nurse and she goes ma'am
i too am a nurse oh
you're like my brother is a nurse i'm
like if everybody else is doing it
i too have a nurse but they just started
going back and forth at it and
covered nurse huh yeah and then they're
specific and they kind of went back and
forth and she called her a [ __ ] the
older lady and then me and khalif were
like hey yo come on like don't there's a
her kid's right she's got a fat ass
please yeah
yeah yeah yeah look at that look don't
be talking about batteries look at the
bounce look at the bounce come on yeah
you guys are holding up
i get my drink called and i'm walking up
and i of course have to say one more
thing i was like
you didn't have to do all that you know
and she goes oh shut up to me and i'm
like
before we continue let's talk about our
lovely sponsor skillshare my friends
you guys already know i've been using
skillshare for everything that i need
when it comes to learning a
skill that i want to either improve on
or just learn in general right now i'm
taking a course called productivity for
creatives because
i'm trying to get my life in order i
have a lot of creative ideas but
majority of the times when i put pen to
the paper i kind of just don't know what
to do with it well the productivity part
of this is where i suffer and this
course has helped me a lot
and by the way this is just a specific
course that i'm taking they have a bunch
of courses for
everything i know a lot of people are
into video right now or even writing
there's oh let me tell you something the
adobe premiere
tutorials on here have saved my ass
specifically when it comes to editing
there's so many courses that you can
take
and if you're out there and you're
itching to learn something new
or you don't even know where to start
skillshare can be those online
courses of force use my friends what
happened to my english what's going on
here
skillshare my friends just to give you
guys a little bit more specificity
is an online learning community that
offers membership with meaning with so
much more to explore
real projects to create and the support
of fellow creative skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real
growth now my genius brain listeners
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
brain and get a free trial of premium
membership
at skillshare.com brain once again
that's skillshare.com
brain [ __ ] are you gonna [ __ ] make
me yeah what are you gonna do
right and then she goes you people and
then they'll oh yeah right when she
called me that i was like
i have been waiting and there was
right cause i i've always wanted to say
back to somebody you people back to them
with a question mark yeah but she was
like
you people and i didn't even get to say
it because everybody defended me
so the lady behind the counter she comes
up she goes whoa whoa man man excuse me
that is
racist and so she looks at the other
girl behind the counter right
who looks like a white girl and she goes
and the lady who uh
who called me you people she goes i
can't be racist she goes i'm mexican
could have fooled me she looks white
yeah and the white girl behind the
counter she
goes i'm also mexican
everybody's a nurse and mexican in this
story and then i jumped and i was like
yeah
escuela she's like school
wow
these two ladies start yelling at each
other in spanish
i'm like bro this is [ __ ] nuts it's
like racist pokemon dude he's like you
got attacked by a pokemon you called
your mexican pokemon and then they got
yeah i like the battle for you she can't
be racist because she's mexican
what do you mean so what you can't be
racist this is the [ __ ]
topper this is how crazy this lady was
right and this at this whole time like
she goes [ __ ] you guys are all crazy
i'm out of here yeah and i felt bad
because the lady had her kids there she
had a carriage
look into the carriage [ __ ]
there's two chihuahuas
for real almost the whole time
oh my god bro [ __ ] pasadena gets a
little weird
people are wild man the thing about the
coronavirus stuff people just love
to uh that's crazy they love to try to
[ __ ] like regulate [ __ ] like that you
know like
i'm better than you i'm six feet apart
my buddy ariel [ __ ] one of our buddies
that we i grew up with i've known him
from
kindergarten very handsome man he's uh
mexican in chilean but he's
he's like darker darker skinny brown guy
and uh he's my best friend like growing
up and
he he grew up in south pasadena and he
got into that at that same intersection
they were driving he got in this little
like road rage incident this lady was
like trying to cut him off and all this
[ __ ]
the train comes or whatever or no it was
just a red light and then uh this lady
like him and this lady are like dogging
each other and he's like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
like he's like just flicking her off and
then she's like look she rolls her
window down it's an older white lady and
she's like get out of our town
yeah our team i always when he told me
that i was i add the brown
because i just like that like i have our
town brown like just
like he's a [ __ ] crayola crayon or
something bro he said he like
he he like blacked out this dude has a
temper and he's like he's like i got out
of my car and i approached
he's like i didn't know what i was gonna
do he's like i didn't know if i was
gonna beat her ass
i didn't know but he said he was just
like i gotta start walking to her she
just
bolted through the [ __ ] red light
just jammed out but get out of our town
brown
yeah she added brown crayola crayons
that is some old-fashioned racism that
is old fashioned right there i
appreciate it
get out of our town brown she didn't
really say brown but
she said brown you know i love when
someone when an old purse old white
person says like
you go back to where you come from
because it's like it's a very generic
but very still good it still gets you
very upset
and all those people are starting to die
off anyways dude yeah not all of you
because i was i don't know if this guy
was racist or not but he seemed like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he was i was walking on a target and he
was in a handicapped spot
and uh he was reversing but we already
walked past his car but like as
we were walking past to the driver's
side he backed up
and i looked over my shoulder and he
kind of like almost hit us but he wasn't
really close but
he's like looking and i just looked on
my shoulder and i was like who the [ __ ]
almost hit us you know
and it's like this old the oldest man
you've ever seen
oldest man and he just flips out his
finger like [ __ ] you
and i'm like why [ __ ] me bro you just
hear all the joints crack
you and the dust comes out of his mouth
but yeah like he's like
[ __ ] you like that just flicking me off
football people [ __ ] [ __ ] you so then
he pulls out and i just look at him and
i'm just like looking like hey what's up
dude like i'm like waving at him because
i was gonna fight that old man bro i'm
gonna beat him i knew i could have went
i could have won that once
maybe this is his debatable yeah yeah so
so you know i i [ __ ]
banged on his windshield i was like
what's up dude let's go he banged this
off you bang those winches no i made
that up for the story but like that
would have been really cool if i did
wow and if i picked on an old man old
yeah you don't look right in any of the
situation did you just look at an
[ __ ] right now
i didn't do nothing i just i just waved
to him and i was like alright see you
later and that was it cool
and then i [ __ ] broke his hip wow so
why do you hate jeremy lin
i don't hate you i love jeremy bro
lindsay
was one of my one of my favorite moments
of all time in my life
nothing brought our family together
closer than jeremy lin
i've never seen our whole family uncles
i'm serious lynn saves families
he saved our family but then completely
deteriorated after that
yeah but like i remember when where is
he now yeah yeah
we're doing it my dad moved to taiwan he
was like jeremy lin can't make it in the
league and he went he left he'd bounce
yeah he went to go watch him to see
families yeah exactly but he also brings
them together
um but i remember when the lakers played
the new york knicks and that morning the
insanity game
against kobe all our family was just
cheering in the house i've never seen
our family be so collected together
but your parents just started [ __ ]
each other yeah right and i was like i
was like this is
always you i was like thank god
uh but i don't hate jeremy lin bro let
me tell you something we're in the park
and he said that
and i we're discussing the whole jeremy
lin thing uh-huh he immediately started
laughing he goes that's hilarious
because you know what it sounds like it
just sounds like [ __ ] talking bro like
you play ball before you know what it's
like when you play with it it's like i
[ __ ] your mom and i'm like hey bro
i'm showing you the free throw relax who
called who called him chronova he said
one of the players
uh that he was playing against called
him coronavirus but i'm like bro
jeremy you're dropping the 30 a game
right now you're balling out you're
going to the league my guy
yeah you know you're probably just upset
because you're just doing dope yeah
right you're
falling out you've been there before you
have a championship
ring that's right and you're in the gym
league he's [ __ ] balling
and he's still balling up he's balling
out of control right now so these foes
are going to talk [ __ ] let them talk
[ __ ] bro you drop 30 every night yeah
i'm pretty sure it happened but the
first thing when i hear somebody say
it's just
that insult is so dry yeah you know what
i mean i thought
it's a throwaway one right it's a very
throwaway insult too it sounded like a
little bit of a juicy smoothie situation
yeah so i was like oh i just want to
know the context
because what like if you're competing
against jeremy lin and you really want
to get into what people apologize right
here
no no if if you want to get in jeremy
lin's head and you're playing basketball
them you got to be like hey chinese
people are like this
korean eye like this yeah and you do
that yeah and he's gonna be
[ __ ] pissed dude that's how you get
in his [ __ ] head maybe that's the
reason why he's been scoring 30 points
and his coach actually paid that guy to
do it
maybe yeah he's going to leave bro it's
like say the most racist [ __ ] ever i
can't do it coach i'm not racist
i can't do it at all i just want to know
how the question was asked like oh like
or how it even came about but like when
you hear that i'm just like yeah i bet i
bet that happens
and that's like sports there's a lot of
terrible [ __ ] that people say to each
other oh yeah people say
wild [ __ ] bro i wish like the nfl or
even basketball
turn off the announcers just i want to
hear what they say to each other i want
to hear all the nasty
talking racist [ __ ] ever yeah i want to
like but you can click a button you can
hear the announcers or all the [ __ ] they
say i would
a hundred percent love to hear
everything they say i bet you it's
terrible
you ever hear kevin garnett like uh
miked up like the uh
where he'll just say [ __ ] loud as [ __ ]
where actually
he won't be miked up but he'll yell it
so loud where you could hear it through
the broadcast
and he's like there's a compilation on
youtube and you can hear him say the
wildest [ __ ] like what
like your mama's [ __ ] takes a good last
night like [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
like king's [ __ ] hilarious things i
can't say yeah anything is possible
well he's trying to stab a [ __ ]
bro you ever seen him in uh
uncut gems that really happened bro he
was that kind of guy he's actually
pretty good in that movie he's really
good yeah i was it was like
how good his acting was yeah it wasn't
bad he's like i gotta hold this one one
more name bro
that movie was [ __ ] great that movie
was so good i was so anxious to have a
[ __ ] time
what the [ __ ] what are we doing with our
lives man we got to be an adam sandler
man
we gotta start gambling or some [ __ ] we
gotta start you know that's what we
gotta start doing that's where we gotta
go huh yeah just start you know um
what's
what's wrong i'm looking for i don't
know anything about gambling so i'm not
gonna continue this
okay let's do a very dark alleyway with
nothing
and i'm just looking at you guys looking
at me and i'm like yeah what are you
thinking
how do you like comedy man so you're
pretty funny guy what you tell this joke
yeah my jokes are so korean so korea's
eyes are like
yeah yeah you just gotta make the bit
better yeah yeah how would you improve
that joke i
i wouldn't do it i think i think that's
how you improve the joke you're not
doing it yeah i just
don't do that yeah patrick you're known
for your racial humor aren't you uh
no not at all we were talking about
yesterday how [ __ ] uh
because i did okay let me tell you about
this [ __ ] all right let me tell you
the most disorganized human beings on
earth
in the [ __ ] mma show podcast we out
here baby yeah
podcast okay okay the most disorganized
[ __ ] ever so
gilbert texted me he goes hey you gotta
do our podcast i go i [ __ ] yeah
doesn't give me a time it's a saturday
night by the way or a day right
okay i'm just waiting yeah i'm like oh
they're probably not gonna do it
whatever
i just move on and then the next nick
texted me he goes so he down to the
podcast tonight
what the [ __ ] okay nobody told me [ __ ]
they just said are you down to do a
podcast and they just left it open
so i can disorganize [ __ ] i'm
gonna pass the buck to gilbert because
this is what true teammates and homies
do is you just throw your buddies under
the bus
but gilbert is in charge of booking our
guests that's what we call it we book
our guests
but with our 200 300 views
he he's the one that's supposed to reach
out to everybody he does it all the time
so
as soon as he asked you i was like oh he
probably hit up david
and was like all right this is the time
we're gonna do it yeah you gotta get up
and then he texted me on
monday because when we shot it and he
goes hey can you text david
uh and let him know that we're gonna
film tonight and in my head i'm
like this [ __ ] didn't hit him up
he's hitting him up
right now that's exactly what happened
and he's like hey nick you go do it so
i'm like
all right i text david and i just hear
like lol on caps
he's like you [ __ ] just hit me
up you got i don't i'm not
gonna even be home tonight [ __ ]
i just [ __ ] went
i was like well [ __ ] whatever i was
doing i'll just come a little early
whatever yeah because i care what were
you and you did it i did
oh wow he's a true homie bro that is a
true homie right there and so that's why
we're going to get rid of gil
he is the worst and david is going to
replace him
we're talking about [ __ ] um i was
just reading more about it today and he
just started pissing me off even more
was [ __ ] paulo acosta
yeah and his stupid excuses bro
that's what he was claiming he drank the
whole bottle of wine
and got drunk the night before and
that's like that dumb ass
he keeps getting more and more unlikable
like do you think like it's like i
already don't like you enough and then
he just comes out with another way for
me to like him less like dude what a
[ __ ] loser bro
just accept the loss it happened a long
time like not a long long time ago but
a while ago you got to [ __ ] accept
the loss learn from it and get get over
it and [ __ ]
keep training bro what the [ __ ] like
when you're training really hard and
you're eating really clean and you're
trying to make a weight class of 185
there's a lot of dieting and cleaning
that goes into that
right why the [ __ ] are you drinking wine
the night before
the biggest fight of your career right
and not only just a little bit of wine a
whole bottle a whole
bottle of wine a title fight exactly
because the excuse
still doesn't make him look good no
makes him look like an [ __ ]
yeah it's like you're an idiot you're an
idiot bro it's like what are you doing
no one asked you to drink a bunch of
wine before yeah and on top of that his
his excuse probably what i'm thinking is
he thought this excuse was gonna like
everyone's for some reason was going to
be like oh [ __ ]
paula costa totally has a shot now well
his first excuse wasn't even that great
because he couldn't sleep
he goes i didn't sleep well yeah who the
[ __ ] cares nobody sleeps well before
they fight what are you talking about
everyone's nervous as [ __ ] that's
common that's very common yeah he
probably he probably saw conor mcgregor
like up with the khabib talk about how
he would get [ __ ] up all the time
and then was probably like oh maybe like
i could use that too i'm thinking so
maybe that's probably exactly
what it was because like but with connor
it's like that dude was out of hand so
you can believe it like that dude was
that that was just
knocking phones out of people saying
like he was wild like that press
conference with habib
and connor oh yeah bro that [ __ ] was the
weirdest press conference i've ever seen
yeah he was he was off the rails
yeah he was like screaming you [ __ ]
mad rat you [ __ ] mad [ __ ]
yeah just screaming that the whole time
yeah dude people had [ __ ]
mumps bro he had mumps did you see the
picture of him because he was
[ __ ] up dude he had moms that's like a
deadly disease that's an old-timer it's
like a bubonic plague
yeah yeah yeah boy hassan was writing a
song about the moms
that's what he was thinking about he had
the [ __ ] mumps
and he got barely got over it and then
he fought so they really did you see the
picture of his face
it's [ __ ] nuts dude it looks it looks
like it's photoshopped before that
doesn't look real no before uh the
justin
oh but paulo costa bro
the [ __ ] are you you're supposed to be a
professional athlete you're drinking a
bottle of wine before the fight
if that's even true yeah hey look at
this well this will looks like [ __ ]
alex dude whoa
dude it's like decent it does look like
a filter what the [ __ ] this is his face
with mumps
that looks like the fatify filter on he
looks like the nutty professor but like
and then he [ __ ] obliterates with
this [ __ ] disease
how long was that before the actual
fight though it was like a week or some
[ __ ] and his face went down to normal in
that amount of time holy [ __ ] that's why
that fool was crying how do you catch
the mumps dude i don't know that's like
a muppet like a muppet disease yeah
he didn't make no [ __ ] excuse he
didn't say [ __ ] yeah he's not a big
ass jon jones he did a whole line of
coke and [ __ ] a bunch of hookers yeah
but that's good for fighting though
that's good all right whatever
that's good it keeps you that keeps
[ __ ] coke yeah yeah bro is that what
you did
no have you done hard drugs before no
just uh the only thing i've done is
marijuana marijuana
marijuana mushrooms you've done
mushrooms we dropped we did some
mushrooms after our wedding
oh you microdosed right oh what was that
like it was great how'd you feel
i felt great what did you what'd you
experience i just felt happy
that was it it was very faint you took a
little bit though right no i took a good
amount i took a couple caps
um and he was like oh yeah you take this
much and then
and then my lady took some too whoa yeah
yeah
you probably won't be happy that i said
that but how'd she feel how'd she feel
she had a really good trip dude
she had a really she was she did you
guys [ __ ] on mushrooms no no we were on
the beach
we were on the beach and um we haven't
had sex here we haven't consummated a
thing yet uh
um virgin yeah we're holding out for
10-year anniversary oh perfect 10-year
wedding anniversary perfect
so 20 years in total that's what we're
waiting for well
that's what that's what you guys are
doing right oh absolutely
your pat's a virgin too so oh yeah yeah
married i am
i'm looking like that i'm true oh yeah
so how did you have that kid
don't worry about it right uh yeah dude
it was great like
what made you want to take the the
psychedelics it wasn't my idea
it was your lady's idea it was my wife
wow
hey we should try it she's going to put
a finger in your butt i already know hey
sure
coming next can i tell you something
this is this is going to be matt like
she likes to credit card in my butt
cheeks oh yeah she does
and at first i was she thinks it's funny
right she's loosing you up with the
she's buttering you up with the
psychedelics and then she's gonna be
like strap on [ __ ] studded
yeah you're ready and then i'll be like
no let's use mine and i'll pull mine out
whoa you carry it like a sword yeah it's
like that yeah you're like link yeah
that's exactly what it is okay perfect
so uh we're talking about you guys are
talking yeah she's like she she likes
the credit card in my butt cheeks right
and um what y'all i know i just thought
of something i'm bringing it back to the
credit yeah go ahead
okay so she likes to credit my butt
cheeks and at first i'd be really jumpy
but now i'm pretty cool with it man now
it's like yeah she could probably slide
a finger up in there and i'll be good
according to her plan you guys do that
too right a lot of things i didn't need
to know
five minutes didn't even know anything
you can't ao
i'm gonna literally look this part up
timestamp
and send it and we're gonna yeah i'm
just gonna send her this clip and be
like this is what we say we just talk
[ __ ] about you and your
butthole pleasures the whole time that's
what we're talking about yeah tips on
the buttholes would you bring me ask you
something
okay what's up do i google buttholes on
on google images yeah what's wrong with
you dude
hey bro you asked the questions i
answered that's my that's my role here
that's it is ayahuasca and shrooms the
same thing
i think they're no they're different i
think uh i don't know
specifically what they are i think
there's like a couple versions of dmt or
something and
uh i think they're like there's like a
three and a five or some [ __ ] i know
somebody who did dmt and had a really
bad trip
after that i'm like i don't want to try
this yeah really uh
what happened i'm gonna call him a he
okay it could be a she or whatever so
it's a her continue it's a pretty [ __ ]
up story
but basically this dude [ __ ]
artist right so they there's like these
moments where i don't know artists
always feel like they have to
they're like in this like artistic rut
or something or yeah something about
people when they live in la they always
feel like they
i'm not growing enough there's no growth
here you know this is like the popular
things that people say in the city
so this person was doing perfectly fine
had a coffee shop and everything else
like that
was happily married whatever right so
this dude
decides to go meet up a bunch of other
people like on reddit or some [ __ ] and
they're they're going to oh yeah of
course
in ayahuasca a terrible idea yeah when
you do ayahuasca apparently
um you have somebody who kind of
moderates [ __ ] and watches you to shop
that you're not the shaman i guess i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is
hassan yeah the shaman's name was gary
hi my name is garrell you go on today
they go off either it was like joshua
tree or some [ __ ] and they go off right
yeah off into like the desert or the
[ __ ] forest
uh decides to do a little ayahuasca
right
has like the cool kids weird [ __ ]
trip
freaks the [ __ ] out throws up yaks like
everybody else does
but has comes to the conclusion that he
needs to divorce his wife
uh sell all of his worldly possessions
and then quit everything he's doing
goes back divorces his [ __ ] wife and
then uh
sells his part of the coffee shop and
[ __ ] leaves him and then tries to go
off on a spiritual journey
don't know what the [ __ ] happened to
this dude he comes back and then
he finally snaps out of it right and it
took like a couple of months i don't
know what the [ __ ] happened to his brain
right snaps out of it comes back and
says i just made the biggest
[ __ ] mistake of my life i miss my
[ __ ] wife like i missed the previous
life that i
had in those two three months or
whatever dude finds another
uh she finds another [ __ ] uh dude and
so
his whole [ __ ] past life is gone
because when he took ayahuasca he had
like the spiritual revelation
the spirits were talking to him telling
him that what he's doing right now isn't
the right way he shouldn't be eating
meat and all this other [ __ ]
so i i don't know wow do you think
that's just what he thinks in his brain
and then it just came about i don't know
people believe that whole ayahuasca trip
is like you in another [ __ ] dimension
but yeah but do you think like some of
it is like the subconscious of like the
things that you think is true
and then it brings it to light a little
bit could be
i've never done it before so but did you
do mushrooms
no i don't i don't like drugs though
it's not my [ __ ] yeah the only thing i
take is
cbd farmhouse guys hey you know we got
some
pretty dope we gave it i gave it to
tiff's mom and she loves it it's [ __ ]
fantastic
i'm telling you it's
i think you gave us the the ones with th
i felt something
i honestly i didn't feel like sober
this whole microdosing dude i like i
felt good i was happy
i felt great i was like are you sure
there's not edibles because i was like
this is the best high i've had in a
really long time
it's very calming it's very nice yeah it
wasn't that [ __ ] because i went on that
[ __ ]
death hike all the way up in how was it
oh yeah how was it
it looked scary the [ __ ] do you think it
was like it was one of the most
frightening experiences of my life
here's the funny thing right so we have
this buddy named darian right yeah
darian is
a [ __ ] cambodian billy goat like the
way he climbs and scales these mountains
you would think that there was magnets
on his feet he didn't use his hands at
all
he just has like a gopro gopro 360 with
the stick and he's just climbing up with
his feet
i'm talking this [ __ ] is like a slant
like a solid like i don't know what
what's the degree 45. it's vertical
basically he's walking up like this
yeah i'm i have a
deathly fear of heights like i'm [ __ ]
scared of heights same
and so he has this conversation with joe
telling himself like hey
i can get anybody do anything now mind
you he did get me
to scale this [ __ ] mountainside right
okay okay and so
this is the funny thing that people
always say to me that it's a little
annoying
but makes me laugh he goes don't you
feel accomplished i look dead into this
man's eyes i said [ __ ] you
i was like what do you mean i was like i
don't think you understand you can only
feel accomplished
i would feel accomplished if climbing a
mountainside was a part of my [ __ ]
bucket list yeah it was never a part of
my bucket list
i don't care yeah i don't remember
anything i was that scared wow
and the only reason why it's called ptsd
my guy the
only reason why i could re um i even got
up there was because of my cbd farmhouse
products there you go
yeah yeah it really did though it helped
with like the anxiety i'm sure yeah but
then there was one part of the [ __ ]
mountain
where you got you go off trail past this
waterfall and it's these two
huge [ __ ] slabs of rocks that you
have to
zigzag up and then when you get to the
top part when you peek your head out
that [ __ ] [ __ ] rock
you look over to the right and it's just
a death drop wow so
i didn't know this and my cbd [ __ ]
wore off at this point
so my anxiety is already through the
roof oh no i look over
i get vertigo oh no and the [ __ ]
world starts to spin
and i had to sit down and this little
[ __ ] rocket sit there for like five
minutes
but then the only thing was is like
everybody else was climbing i can't get
back down by myself so i have to go up i
don't have a [ __ ] choice
so i just kept telling myself david your
child is up there and you need to save
this little [ __ ]
so i just had to create these random
scenarios wow and i somehow start
scaling it but i
literally had a crawl that's why my
forearms are all [ __ ] scratched the
[ __ ] up
because i was crawling on my [ __ ]
knees and my [ __ ]
arms just on all fours like a little
[ __ ] bro you guys be doing too much dog
i'm telling you that's not a hike that's
you guys went bolder where was this
where was this it's uh
escondido escondido falls i've heard it
i don't know where that is i don't
want to do that we ain't doing that [ __ ]
bro bro you had a scale so like like a
ninja where you have your hands on the
foot like that like you got to put your
back
to the lock and then kind of zigzag
while that [ __ ] u2 song vertigo was
playing
it's so [ __ ] funny too because i
remember it was two girls right
very sweet sweet and i probably wouldn't
have been able to do without without
them because they were very very
supportive
i'm pretty sure they lost all respect
for me though i am 100 because david the
whole time was like
don't tell me what to do you [ __ ]
[ __ ] just like just yelling and that's
exactly what i said
so there's something get away from me so
my friend gigi right
i love gigi did that she's been on this
podcast before and she goes you could do
it you could do it here give me your
head i was like get your [ __ ] hands
away from me
you're gonna go save me [ __ ] i was like
i will really drag you to the depths of
hell
get the [ __ ] off me like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass cut
[ __ ]
i'm just climbing my way all the way up
oh my god but they knew it wasn't out of
a place of hate it was
out of a place of fear yeah yeah but i
will never
ever ever do anything like that again i
don't remember [ __ ]
wow that's so crazy yeah i only remember
whatever was recorded so from what i see
in the video
but i don't remember what the trail
looks like that's how scared i was
that's [ __ ]
what does vertigo feel like because i've
always heard of it but i don't i don't
know have you ever
like gone to the city and then looked up
at a skyscraper oh yes in the whole
that's what vertical is okay it's really
just like you start to fall over
yeah that's so weird so could you
imagine doing that when there's like a
vertical drop that'll [ __ ] kill you
oh my god so how did you guys get down
i don't know don't add i don't remember
i just literally got on my app oh this
is what i did
i basically so here's the other thing
when they tell you
uh you're going on a [ __ ] hike when
you tell somebody who lives in la
you're gonna go on a hike you're
thinking it's a paved roadway yeah
it was not it was only like that for the
first like half and the other half
you're just climbing
and it's all dirt and rocks i had
[ __ ] ultra boost on
so i was slipping and forgotten oh my
god everywhere that's the worst
dude that's the [ __ ] worst yeah so i
was scared [ __ ] shitless
and so on the way back down i literally
have video footage of me
just scooting my ass like a dog with an
itchy ass on the carpet
like a mile down having these rocks
[ __ ] me for a [ __ ] mile
it was the [ __ ] worst oh my
shout out to my boy darian too because
it's full right before we hit this spot
we're supposed to start scaling this
[ __ ] mountainside
he goes dude the other day this person
thought he was done with the trail
jumped and snapped his [ __ ] leg and
the bone just shot out right
out of his leg cool thanks man i'm like
he goes you ready you're right
darian what the [ __ ] guy are you insane
you're ready he's wearing off
he's motivated by fear that guy wow dude
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dude that's insane
that's unbelievable yeah [ __ ] all hikes
like that dude
okay bro i don't got to be climbing no
mountains i
don't want to be scaling things nope i
just want to walk
uphill in a nice incline get my steps
that's
it that's it i don't know how to climb
mountains like i had to like
let's see this [ __ ] too little [ __ ]
little hole in my hand from a rock
so i was slipping so much oh i just
remember this part
i was slipping so much and these hands
were so [ __ ] scraped up
i i grabbed two flat rocks like this big
and i started using that instead because
the rocks were scraping up the bottom of
my palms
so this this and he goes don't you feel
good
about yourself right now accomplished
sir [ __ ] you dude
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
you're like some wartime [ __ ] dude
yeah i gotta use rocks
this city got people [ __ ] up man it's
so crazy like i don't
understand it's like i i don't feel good
and joe felt bad because joe didn't
remember
what the hike was like and when we got
halfway there he don't remember nothing
he's like oh [ __ ] i think this is
actually a lot more difficult than i
thought i'm like
i'm already here i got ultra busan what
are we doing
it's too late oh my god [ __ ] that bro
and then
the part that he said he goes you know
the part that we just did he goes that
was actually
the worst part he lied it was nowhere
near as difficult as that last hike
there's it's not even a a trailed height
people just go up there
so how long was this hike to me it felt
like 18 hours
but i believe it was three hours that's
so long bro that's to be like climbing
like that and [ __ ] like that's why my
lips are all [ __ ] they got sunburned
really yeah i didn't know your lips
could get sunburned david had a heat
stroke on this
one yeah so my lips got sunburned and
then my allergies were going so [ __ ]
crazy
oh my god like i kept on rubbing my nose
that's why i have no skin right here
yeah bro allergies
that's it bro my allergies been [ __ ]
up bro you almost died dude yeah and
then i got i get home right
i have to edit a whole [ __ ] podcast
that night the longest day of my [ __ ]
life he's crying the whole time is
oh my god so i was so i don't know what
happened i [ __ ] up my adrenals or some
[ __ ] but the next day
midday six hour nap i was out yeah just
[ __ ] out probably the stress the fear
the [ __ ] the actual physical i
thought i had verona because i had a
fever too but it was just from the
stress
david would tell me like not extreme
stories like this but he would tell me
stories where
he would be really stressed from
something or
whatever and then like sleep all day and
i used to be like man
david [ __ ] this full line he just
lined and get out of training
but the more i hear these stories the
more i'm like
that's just david that's just me baby
okay some people like some people
like just have they can't just do [ __ ]
like they just they don't have the
mental capacity to like
do things like that because you know
like we have most of like my friends
growing up
they were always be able to roll with
the punches you know i mean like we
would do crazy [ __ ]
and they'd be fine but sometimes you got
to watch out for your friends
that you know may not be well equipped
enough to handle certain situations
in three minutes you could have just
called me a [ __ ]
that was the longest description of a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] at the
end of the day
some people just you know just aren't
causing dancing around it he goes you
know some of our friends aren't as well
equipped
right penises all right and i'm one of
them the penis
simply looks like two flaps yeah yeah
like vulvas
my point the little thing is just watch
out for your friends
watch out for your friends type of [ __ ]
you're a politician i'm not bro i'm just
saying because
that's what i think of i'm like [ __ ]
because i know a lot of people in the
comments are like david shut the [ __ ] up
that
that never happened you're lying you
know and i got witnesses listen
[ __ ]
david's got issues all right i got real
issues
that's the weird thing you know what the
internet they're like recorded or it
doesn't
it didn't happen but just like normal
people just kind of experience life yeah
they don't just whip out their [ __ ]
camera
every time something happens for clout
like exactly david if david
recorded himself doing this hike david
probably would have died i would have
been
dead and i was so lucky that i had joe
to laugh at me and record me for it
how fortunate he's wearing like no
clothes climbing this [ __ ] mountain
like nothing
and just living the day have the videos
let me show you guys yeah
pull them up we saw the videos and i was
like dude this looks way too high i saw
a couple clips that you posted but you
look like you're having fun kind of
though oh you
don't know me at all you son of a [ __ ]
just i'll picture you and the bag these
girls posing and you in the back like
he lane like he's having a good time
he's up there he's up there yeah yeah
dude
that's the hole that you go in that you
have to climb out of and then you see
this it looks
plain here but that's just a drop on the
other side are these the girls giving
you emotional support yeah they're like
you can do it i believe in you i'm so
proud you know what that trail looks
like
it looks like nobody should go there
exactly yeah it looks terrible it looks
like they're it shouldn't be inhabited
by humans like getting coming out of a
manhole or something
yeah bro and there's also which is so
funny you see this this is literally
scooting down the mountain on my ass
hey look at your white ass shoes dude
yep
and so if you look over here to this
side it's just a drop yeah
it's literally just a drop that's it
you're dead
these girls are walking and you're like
yo [ __ ] these nice ass [ __ ] dude
i told you about exaggerating my story
for real now let me tell you bro when i
was in hawaii i had no traction on my
shoes
i ate [ __ ] so many times that's what i i
feel like i'm pretty coordinated
and tiff was chilling bro she was
laughing at my ass like i was a
i was i slipped and fell on some rocks
and i fell backwards and i tried to
catch my balance i slipped again
there was a stick sticking out like this
literally my ass
fell right on it bro i'm noticing a
theme dude i had a bruise right on the
inner cheek dog
right and then [ __ ] tip was like i've
prepared you for this
yeah yeah swipe and the bruising went
away right away
yeah but yeah you know what man i'm i'm
happy for you david you did something
that you were very scared of actually
i don't yeah no idea yeah he had no idea
why he don't remember
anything don't [ __ ] care i feel like
david always gets roped into some
situations where like you know what i'm
a down-ass [ __ ] that's why you are you
are
but i bet i bet joe was like let's just
not tell him like how crazy that is no
joe didn't remember
yeah joe literally when he we got to the
point where he was getting a little
crazy he goes
oh [ __ ] and you saw his face yeah that's
when joe had to really help me he goes
all right man
because when people are experienced in
climbing and hiking they can see things
that i don't see
yeah so though like joe at first was
like all right put your foot on that
rock i'm like
what rock you're all the same it looks
like
dirt what do you go that rock right
there and then he has to point it out
and there was like a video game with a
red circle pops up
you're gonna put your post your hand up
here use your momentum and then thrust
your body up
and then put your leg on this rock but
in my mind i'm thinking because i'm
strong your boy's
a strong man a strong ass i thrust too
far i'm going to rock it out to the
other side
and you have vertigo the whole time yeah
exactly exactly so it was one of the
worst experiences of my life yeah that's
that's [ __ ] awful a scary hike is
well [ __ ] the height [ __ ] is a whole
nother because i'm not a big fan of
heights either
uh i went to zion one time and there's a
hike up there called angel's landing
and the whole time you go high but it's
basically like paved road i mean it
turns into dirt but it's like kind of
you know it's nice
and you go up and you go you're starting
to get really high it starts getting
windy you're like okay but it's like you
feel safe because it's like a path
you know then there's a there's an end
point and then there's
uh uh like a skinny little narrow
walkway
and it gets to the last like probably
like 150 yards
but the last 150 yards are this it's
it's like a narrow piece
it's a very tall mountain you keep going
up very narrow there's two
single-fold lines and on the rocks
there's chains
like you gotta hold on to chains and
people are moving like ants so basically
you're like when we did this [ __ ] you're
holding on to a chain like this
there's you're maybe walking on
something like about literally about
this narrow and it's all rocks
and then down there it's like you're on
like a skyscraper like length
[ __ ] that cannot do that so i i was like
i was like it took me a while to be like
but i want to make it to the end
but there's people literally sitting in
the middle crying yeah people like this
like
[Applause]
literally look like a like a [ __ ]
saving private right you know why it's
called angel's landing is
cause probably people die up there yeah
i do no you honestly people do die
people have died it's very if you slip
if you [ __ ] up you will
die there's another there's another hike
called echo mountain that my brother
used to jog up and there's like
[ __ ] like coyotes and bobcats coyotes
bears and [ __ ] deers up there and
[ __ ]
he takes me there and he didn't tell me
that this place like i'm talking about
the road is as wide as this couch is
yeah and then it's just a straight drop
off like you just you could be in the
clouds that's what it looks like it's
the bridge to nowhere it leads up there
[ __ ] that but you can
literally like who names this [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so
is you're trying to be scary and [ __ ]
that was a hike i couldn't remember what
it was like
and it just i can't do it again i had to
stop and sit down
and be like you know what you guys go
all the way up and you have to come get
me because i can't do this
yeah yeah it was too hard and this was
when i didn't have cpd at that time so i
was just sitting there just
curled up as a at a ball like this
couldn't [ __ ] do it and right before
we got up there was a missing person
poster right there and
we found out later on through the
internets that [ __ ] fell off and
died
cool why yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] why do we
do this the coconut trail
in hawaii yeah did you were you scared
doing that one i was scared but it's
more manageable there's a wide road and
it's a lot more stable
for real but that [ __ ] we were [ __ ]
kind of tripping
we were kind of tripping on because that
[ __ ] was kind of scary because tiff was
like
she's not she don't really hike that
much she doesn't really like doing that
much physical activity
but i was like really surprised that she
got up there but like when you see
how high it is and how steep it is from
like the freeway
we were like i can't believe we [ __ ]
did that [ __ ] yeah it's exhausting
because it is kind of scary like we we
people were saying like oh it's super
easy you just breeze right through it
but low key i was like oh this [ __ ] kind
of you're high here
the easiest one is diamond head yeah i
never we have we didn't
we didn't do that it's like man made so
you're fine okay
but there was [ __ ] running up
it's like steep as [ __ ] like it's super
steep
muriel's so [ __ ] funny man so when we
when we
uh we went to diamonds
i don't think she knew how scared of
heights i was right so she wanted to go
to diamond head and all of her friends
are doing it together
and i'm not having a good time i'm
literally only focusing on not dying
yeah that's
it right and so and mind you at this
time your boy like 270 pounds i'm a
[ __ ] fat boy you're a unit right when
i sweat
it's just bacon grease at this point i'm
going up and i'm exhausted i
literally soaked through my shirt and at
the top she goes
let's take a couple pic i'm like can i
just get a second and then where she
looks at me she goes
everybody else is doing it how can we
i'm like look at me
do i look happy look
this shirt was baby blue it's now navy
like
i soaked through this whole shirt oh my
god we got into a [ __ ] fight all the
way down because she was so upset that i
didn't want to do couple [ __ ] with her
but i'm like
i am terrified look into my [ __ ] eyes
they're chinese they're up they're
japanese
but it's funny because like the people
that have taught me about anxiety
in my life has been david and tiff
because i'm that guy where i'm like come
on bro like stop being a bit like let's
just go like i'll say that to tiff like
come on let's go oh yeah whatever i tell
him to put an instagram post and he has
a [ __ ] mental breakdown
what happens if people comment
and they say i don't know what i'm
talking about
[Applause]
[ __ ] but but because talking to david i
was like oh that's what that is
oh and i'm playing this i'm bro i'm
learning [ __ ] about my
my childhood that i'm like oh wait is
that what you call it these days well i
thought i didn't know about my anxiety
stuff too
because back in the day as korean people
call it you're a little [ __ ]
that's all that it is yeah and i'm like
this is a weird type of like complaining
though because this shouldn't affect me
like this this is normal people [ __ ]
yeah it's very frustrating you know
right like ah you just gotta
you were a little anxious yeah just
[ __ ] breathe it out a little bit yeah
somewhere around 1990s is when it
trained
the the the medical term went from
little [ __ ] to anxiety
but i think i think i have some too i
didn't know that but i just i there's
moments where i feel calm and i'm like
oh
this is really nice yeah and i'm like
but why don't i feel like this like all
the time you know
yeah yeah i think it's a spectrum right
like something is triggering everyone's
different
that's the thing too everybody deals
with anxiety yeah at some point right
it's just some of us are extreme
yeah yeah you know where it's just it's
things that are just stupid that makes
you really anxious like
stuff that shouldn't [ __ ] bother you
yeah when i'm when i was
like doing this room and then i didn't
know that you have to let a paint dry
for seven days for it to cure before you
start applying like command strips
and so every time all those phrases yeah
you know either continue
yeah i don't know anything you do every
time david does some new [ __ ]
he becomes an expert on it because he
does all of the research which is fine
which is because of my anxiety exactly
okay and i learned that about david
where i was like oh this dude will be
walking around south pass and he's like
hey do you know this is a garcinia
cambogia and this is a
plant from and i'm like yo what the [ __ ]
how do you know he's actually
resides in phoenix and it's actually not
native to california
have you seen these golden beets and
he'll pull it out like just
what the [ __ ] is this guy bro what is
the command strip dude number one
command strips are based if you want to
put up any type of artwork
whatever and you don't want to damage
the wall it's just it's a sticky
adhesive
yeah i know they're called [ __ ]
command strips that's why all my walls
are damaged
so that's why i use these command strips
and then i found out and i
and i put up a [ __ ] photo it fell
down started pissing me off
and i didn't know why i started getting
anxious so i had to look it up online
and i was freaking out i'm like hold on
a second bro it's a [ __ ]
picture you little [ __ ] relax yeah and
then i just took a cbd and i jacked off
and i was like okay
here you heard it here first guys if you
have anxiety about anything
take cbd farmhouse gummies and you jack
off just notice that if you guys ever
talk to me you meet me and i'm feeling
really anxious i disappear for 10
minutes
you don't know what i did i did the d
that is a good cure though man cbd and
you jerk off
for a guy clears everything if i have a
busy day ahead of me i
always jerk off perfect all decisions
you need
you need to jack off no distractions
clear head nope i can get to work i can
focus
there's nothing like it what's what gets
you a clear head than you jacking it
working out yeah yeah
more more like like like like kickboxing
yeah
yeah but like weights not weights to
help a little bit but like
kickboxing helps me a lot almost to the
the the amount of
it's just that that [ __ ] blood
flowing in you and then yeah
because after we did a few mid sessions
my brain was crispy for like a good two
three hours after that
yeah i should have wrote my [ __ ]
dissertation there you go baby
but that's the thing it only lasts like
three hours four hours then you're like
[ __ ]
all right back to [ __ ] primate then
you gotta [ __ ] then you gotta jerk
off so then
that's how you drove up like this like
this all right yeah you just go straight
for the nub
shout out to my boy john he taught me
this one he came over and showed me how
to do it i showed you
she was like this is a very odd moment
how old are you 22
uh 17. all right nick you're doing it
wrong
there you go there you go for all the
viewers at home check it out this is my
tech
try it out go ahead go for it i don't
only do fitness tips i do this kind of
tips too you know
post that on instagram bro that's good
content hey guys are you having trouble
jacking off at home mm-hmm let's try
this technique
this would have a mental breakdown every
time i told him to just post on
instagram
i just don't like it was the worst thing
i've ever seen in my life
just like i was like dude fitness stuff
on instagram is a
in abundance you know yeah you know what
it is for me it's just like bro
i feel like most people don't like they
know this [ __ ] already yeah
but it's not true people most people
don't know [ __ ]
so you have like imposter syndrome i do
it bro i have crazy imposter syndrome
i have been positive but you have to be
successful to have that first though so
let's start with that
well you know success is different for
everybody
just like anxiety okay levels of success
there's levels of success yeah i was
supposed to be dead 10 years ago when he
started posting on instagram and
started putting out facts and stuff i'm
like wow look it only took him
three [ __ ] years and i was like
yeah you know what it is what it is bro
it's better late than never right
absolutely i hate that no time is
slipping away and uh make sure you guys
capitalize on time am i right
no and my armpits are really sweaty
because you're making me nervous well
guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
weirdo
this is uh this is [ __ ] nick escuelas
this is it baby escuela
you could find nick at nick the ear he
is a personal trainer
he knows he does stuff right what are we
doing
this stuff right yo
when you posted the last one and you did
a little ad i appreciate the little plug
and you're like seriously he's a trainer
i know i make fun of him but he actually
doesn't work and then we have
patrick.t.riley follow him on the
instagram as well i'm on the ground and
then thursdays and sundays you guys the
genius brand podcast and we'll see you
all next time
peace